[Music]
i just realized that
welcome back to another visual effects
artist react video
you guys have probably seen those videos
where like professionals react to videos
pertaining to their career and we want
to do the same thing because visual
effects are super cool
and sometimes they're really bad
the matrix is one of my favorite movies
of all time
i can quote this entire movie
so the matrix honestly is what inspired
me to start getting into visual effects
because
they had a pretty small effects team all
things considered and it was just
really genius application of technology
that made it good all right this shot
right here oh such a revolutionary shot
i love that shot it makes my heart
flutter
the matrix is one of the first films to
kind of pull off one of these shots
where the camera
is just this virtual object that can
move anywhere it wants at any speed
hey you guys want to hear something that
might blow your mind and you too
this background is 100 cg so you're
saying the only thing that's real in
that entire shot is the keanu
the keanu reeves is the only real thing
in that entire shot so the way they did
this shot instead of taking one camera
and moving it through a circle just put
a camera
at each position where there'd be a
frame and just hit a button and they all
take a picture at once
or at least slightly offset from each
other in this case look at that look at
the spacing of those cameras
they knew the speed at which they wanted
to have the camera flying around certain
moments and they built that into the
spacing of the cameras that's crazy i
just realized that i always i always
assumed that they were evenly spaced
there's more frames here in the spin
than there are cameras what they
actually needed to do
is basically do little mini morphs to
get the frames in between the cameras
so you basically have a low frame rate
version and then you go through and you
do frame interpolation it's called which
is basically just morphing from frame to
frame
to fill in those in-betweens and you can
actually see those artifacts
in his uh cape his jacket oh yeah if you
really look at like the folds and
whatnot they do kind of like
morph between each other on certain
frames now here's the thing so they
built a big green screen room there's
all these little holes
you know where the cameras are pointed
through and they filmed counter reeves
on a green screen
what happens when you're doing a 360 rig
and you're on one side of the rig
looking at the other side of the rig
you see all the cameras so they had to
recreate the background in cg
now this is a problem in 1999 because
you don't have
the capabilities to make photorealistic
cg and yet here we are with a
photorealistic background
so why is it photo real nico so the
trick that they came up with was
hey let's just go to our actual set
we'll literally just take pictures of it
as is
with all the lighting already baked in
the shadow's already there and we'll
just use that as a texture
and that's it most people don't notice
this but when trinity does her kick
the background is 100 cg and when agent
smith and neo jump at each other and
they're holding the guns in the subway
the background is also 100 cg in those
shots nice
if you want to remake this shot yourself
all you have to do is get a bunch of
cameras they wouldn't be expensive ones
some green screen poster board and an
actor who flops
and there you go it takes some work but
it's by all means something that's
doable one person
could recreate this effect shot these
days
that is wonky looking he looks like he
has like cotton stuff underneath his
lips he's like hey
i'm superman so okay what actually
happened here is they filmed the justice
league
henry henry cavill or henry cavill henry
uh films
superman and then he goes on to film
mission impossible where he has this
really
cool looking mustache right but during
the filming of that movie they had to do
reshoots
for superman they wouldn't let him shave
his mustache he was contractually
obligated to have a mustache can you
imagine
signing a contract it says you have to
have a mustache at the end of the day
this is just like
movie studios just like flexing at each
other being like oh no we have a
contract saying he can't shave his
mustache
so what are you going to do now like i
guess we'll see g it's
they had to straight up recreate his
entire mouth match it as best they could
and then just composite the the render
over his mustache
but then you have to blend it further in
so you end up having to use more
fake face than the real face to make it
all work together and then you end up
with basically a mostly fake mouth
the hardest thing to recreate about the
face is the lips
it looks not that bad it's not that bad
there this scene is actually pretty
solid
oh this one i've seen this one
the corners of his mouth don't like fold
in on each other correctly yeah that
looks weird
it's too smooth it's way too smooth and
it stretches weird
do you think they took his mustache and
like combed it up
and then combed it down and just like
got a straight like they just crunched
it
together as much as possible straight up
yeah
so this is another example of where
someone did a deep fake over the top of
this and it looks better
deep fakes are pretty interesting
technology the next video coming out on
this channel is us experimenting with
deep fakes if you'd like to check that
out consider subscribing
that looks great i'm seeing some blurry
i can see why they had issues with the
corners of the mouth because the
mustache overlaps the corners of the
mouth and that's really tricky because
you're dealing with two folds of muscle
and skin coming together
it just looks like the guy on the left
just got out of a dental exam
you're right you're you're right you're
just he's got no cane flowing through
his system
is this real life superman
oh man oh man okay one of my favorite
movies
pacific rim had probably the coolest
aesthetic of any movie i've ever seen
sweet guillermo del toro's use of color
i could literally talk about pacific rim
for days
every shot was filmed in a way as if it
was actually achieved in real life
all the camera moves are as if they're
on a dolly or a helicopter or someone's
holding it looking up at the robots
there are no like cg cameras flying all
over the place and that makes these
giant
super unrealistic things seem more real
so that shot we just saw there going
through the office building and then
hitting newton's cradle that's a pretty
cool shot
they filmed that for real on a miniature
set
wait that's not vfx you're right it's
not they created an office building
like third scale maybe
oh that's why it looks so good because
it's real the only thing that added in
that was digital
was the fist and like all the connecting
stuff around the fist in the background
now it is worth noting that the cradle
wouldn't actually react that way this
movie doesn't
care about physics that much
but okay the reason why i wanted to
bring up this movie is to compare it to
the
abysmal second movie oh we're going
there
i never saw it you're not missing out
dude it was just such a disappointment
tiny monsters
i don't want tiny monsters in my
business it's like just this has like
one of those
ethereal cameras where it moves without
any sort of relation to real space
which works for some movies it obviously
works for the matrix but this is an
example where you don't want to do that
because it just kind of reinforces the
idea
that the fake things you're seeing are
actually fake yeah and i'm just watching
an animated film look at this camera
move here
it's a digital camera move and it's just
like flying between each of the jaegers
as they are like powering up their
weapons speed ramps and everything yeah
and
it's like the robots look cool i guess
in the second movie i also noticed that
the jaegers
are faster than the jaegers from the
first movie and that also serves as a
disadvantage for making them look
realistic
what made the jaegers from the first
movie looks so good is the fact that
they were so slow
they were just like in the second movie
like
the bigger you get the slower you move
because you have all these obstacles in
your way like air and whatnot you have
to move really slowly and that really
accentuates the fact that they're huge
if you want your miniatures to look big
you have to shoot them in slow motion
imagine you're standing on top of the
empire state building and you drop a
rock
10 seconds to hit the ground now imagine
you have a 10 foot model of the empire
state building and you drop a rock off
of that
if you want it to look the same size you
would need to slow down time for that
rock to take 10 seconds to hit the
ground
and so that's the kind of math they do
when filming miniatures they change the
frame rate
to make you record slower to make the
physics move at the same speed as they
would if it was a lot bigger do you guys
want to see
the best miniature explosions you've
ever seen
[Music]
salvation yeah you wouldn't think
terminator salvation would have the best
miniature explosion
but these are by far the best miniatures
i've ever seen whoa so they they time
the shock waves with other explosives so
that things all fall apart at the exact
time they should
because obviously your miniature is not
gonna have enough force to blow things
away with a shock wave
watch this there's an explosion for when
it hits the ground boom
see that that timing is nuts you don't
think it's just like a master behind his
like board and just like in true lies i
was like
how did they blow up this massive bridge
and how did this car just plummet into
the ocean and it was with the miniatures
that's real right there it's incredible
i can see the bridge it's coming come on
yes yes yes and it hits that air
and the truck freaking lands it on the
other side of the bridge
yeah man good it's affirmative
oh that's right i forgot about the
pelican dude james cameron with the
goofs man
i think we've had enough of shots that
we really enjoy it's time to look at
something that no one enjoys
whoa whoa
on the baby's face
oh get it off me why it's it's too
mature for his age
so far like all the shots looking down
at the baby aren't that bad but past
when we first see the baby
oh my gosh that was that was hardcore in
caney valley
wait wait go back to that shot go back
to that shot the floating head dude
also there's like way too much fake on
the baby yeah look at that
it's like the baby's clearly lit like
from a different direction and they're
like they're adding fake
shadows like glamour lighting
[Applause]
is it worth going to uh children of men
baby wait you're saying that baby's not
actually there that's completely
computer generated yeah they've be
really good it's
really good one thing to keep in mind is
the lighting helps a lot
all the details are kind of hidden in
the shadows and it makes it look more
realistic because it matches the scene
the animation is fantastic the animation
is really good that looks like a
freaking newborn baby someone had to
hand animate that
every finger every fold
god that was you see i had no idea that
was a cg baby
i remember this oh no we're just looking
at this crosstalk right this is the
crisscross fries i love this scene
there's like the one redeeming scene for
the whole movie
she didn't make it oh that was a good
one
this is pretty crazy because i get the
perspective on her head right when it
falls off oh that was good
super well done that was good stylized
so was that a computer generated head
when i think
i think they had a head model that just
projected the texture of her head onto
it so projecting the texture from your
footage
onto a cg model and then you can just
have that cg model
i think what what happened here is they
just asked the actress
to slowly turn her head and then dip it
down i think so
yeah cause like her ear comes into frame
right it's clearly like rotoed
the bun you know and then they dip her
head forward
and it's just a clean cut they animate
the head down
i think it might be right clint so like
that'd be the easiest and cheapest way
because they're doing it they're doing
this effect when the camera stops
so they orbit around her head they stop
the camera
and now it's easy to do all your stuff
on just a tripod shot basically so
what's this crisscross
shot you keep describing just wait for
it all right this is it he's like yeah
he's gonna do it i gotta do this what is
he gonna do is he gonna like
wrestle with it oh crap crisscross fries
deactivated too late
the eye hmm
some strange animation on that that
looks really cool they got the sear line
yeah the close-up on his face looks
really good oh the oh look at the way
the
i do like that oh man that's really
watch his eye melt though oh nice
the whites are running in his eyes like
it's an egg and it immediately falls
apart once we start seeing like all the
little pieces the first part of that
shot before it rack focuses to her in
the background looks great yeah and now
it's
the physics it's like that little chunk
falls off and then it kind of just kind
of floats there
yeah oh you're right it looks like it
should just tumble off instead it goes
yeah i just think the execution of the
pieces falling apart doesn't look that
great
i agreed so you know who did that shot
way better freddie and brandon
that looks really cool so he's chopping
freddy into hundreds of slices and
pieces here
dude all those blood particles shooting
out on every single slice
oh that's cool that's pretty sweet
example of projection mapping where they
projection mapped
freddy onto a model that's lined up and
then anything that
didn't get the projection map of
freddie's exterior is just a meat
interior
you can see freddie's hand though go
from individual fingers to just
a mitten and you can see the texture
mapping really well on it oh you're all
right
you're right it pops into a into an
inflatable glove
but it's a good transition they fade it
they fade it he does like a cross fade
this was a great shot this is a great
shot there's a whole thing like
effects when you're watching them in
motion in context versus effects
broken down frame by frame played over
and over and over and over again and
most of the little things like that
where his hand went ballooned into a
little inflatable projection map
you don't have to get it pixel perfect
because we don't have time and
no one's going to notice no one's going
to notice yeah you know what we should
do we should react to some of our videos
in a future video
we can look at our best and worst vfx oh
man subscribe for that
and now check this out we have curated a
special playlist of a bunch of our
favorite videos from the last year that
we think you might enjoy having watched
this whole vfx react series so check out
these new videos
link down in the description or you can
click this link right here it'll take
you to several of these videos
they're great and we think you might
enjoy them